on en revient à l'actualité du jour et
les difficultés des républicains aux
dernières élections européennes
ils ont fait 8 5% des voix en 2007 ce
qui s'appelait à l'époque l'ump faisait
31 % des voix c'est à dire à peu près
quatre fois plus si mes comptes sont
exacts 8 et 8 16 32 oui c'est ça à
l'époque c'était nicolas sarkozy qui
était le candidat et certains se
demandent si ce serait pas une bonne
idée de le faire revenir
écouter claude goasguen il est député
les républicains de paris je pense que
nicolas sarkozy doit avoir un rôle
majeur
ne serait ce que pour calmer les
ambiguïtés des antagonismes que je sens
venir dans la famille et les problèmes d
ego ce poste chez nous pour une raison
très simple d'ailleurs c'est que la
perte de vision idéologique et la perte
de vision politique qui remplaçait en
réalité par des soucis tactiques et à
tuer véritablement le modèle
intellectuel de la famille libérale co
liste claude goasguen par le don
antagonismes
sur le plan des positionnements et bien
pour essayer de clarifier un peu tout ça
voici en 45 secondes
une leçon de sciences politiques elle
est administrée par luc ferry ancien
ministre et philosophe
vous avez une droite libérale pro
européenne schumpétérienne en économique
est bien représentée par jean pierre
raffarin ou alain juppé elle est partie
chez makro vous avez une droite
souverainiste keynésienne nationaliste
et est là elle part quand même
globalement plutôt si elle va quelque
part si elle vote c'est plutôt du côté
de le pen ou dupont aignan et vous avez
une droite catholique qui n'a rien à
voir qui est catholique très
conservatrice qui est bien représentée
par la manif pour tous ses sens commun
et qui ne représente qu'une fraction de
du peuple catholique ce le génie de
sarkozy si je puis dire je termine avec
ça pas parler trop longtemps c'était
parler aux trois droite c'est pour ça
qu'il a été élu voilà et pour terminer
de planter le décor avant de lancer le
débat voici un sondage qui vient de
sortir
il a été réalisé par l'institut et là on
a interrogé les français de droite et de
centre-droit pour savoir qui serait le
meilleur leader pour la droite et celui
qui arrive en tête c'est nicolas sarkozy
hervé nathan je sais pas si vous avez
été sondé par elad mais est ce que vous
auriez répondu la même chose ça c'est
français c'est toujours pareil c'est pas
les électeurs de droite c'est parce que
les électeurs de droite souhaitent me
font rire mais se tromper de les
français confie tuant au centre droit
mais est à droite ça donc ils en ont
trouvé d'abord à la mais ce ne sont pas
des sympathisants et des rebonds les
aberrations les a pas vus beaucoup aux
élections donc ils ont réussi à en
trouver dans un sondage c'est très fort
donc c'est bien mais c'est vrai qu'il
suffit de trouver quelques centaines de
personnes
et pas la peine d'aller aux élections
pour ça moi ça m'étonne pas la dernière
fois que la droite s'est reconnu dans la
droite c'était nicolas sarkozy mais pour
m s'est créé il ya deux élections que
saab deux élections présidentielles si
je me souviens bien c'est voilà depuis
il ya un trou
moi je suis assez je trouve que ce que
dit luc ferry est assez est assez juste
et un progrès la droite n'existe plus
sauf à penser pour moi qu'elle est en
très grande partie représenté par la
république en marche les électeurs de ce
ne sont pas trompés si on regarde les
odeurs aux élections européennes les
électeurs ils ont choisi de voter en
conscience parce que je pense qu'il veut
les lecteurs veut toujours en conscience
ils ont voté en conscience pour le parti
pour lequel il avait le plus d'affinités
ça s'appelle la république en marche
et donc si nicolas sarkozy veut revenir
ouais je lui suggère de revenir de
postuler à la république en marche parce
que je pense qu'il ya mensuellement une
place à prendre pour lui alexis lacroix
on pensait qu'il est trop tard entre
guillemets pour un retour de nicolas
sarkozy pas forcément comme leader du
parti mais au moins ils pourraient
prendre la parole j'entends tout ce que
dit hervé j'entends ce que dit lui qui
évidemment la description du paysage
tout ça c'est vrai en revanche la
politique sin dynamite la dynamique
actuellement n'est pas bonne pour la
droite et je ne suis pas de ceux qui
pensent que les losers ont
définitivement
perdu je vais vous dire pourquoi parce
qu'il ya un socle il
comment dire irréfragable de gens ont
leurs 10 12 15 % qui sont des
conservateurs mais qui ne sont
rattrapables ni par le rassemblement
national ni par la forme de modernisme
amodiés par la république et par le
christianisme un christianisme social
que représente le maquereau nisme donc
il ya un mois je crois qu'il ya des
conservateur bon teint en france qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas représentés et
je crois aussi mais c'est pas tout à
fait l'analyse de lutter je crois aussi
que la magie de nicolas sarkozy a été de
savoir rassembler ce qui est épars dans
la droite c'est à dire c'est ou en gros
les trois familles qui l'a décrite
même si je ne suis pas forcément
d'accord sur la typologie raffarin on
peut pas dire que les choux bt rien ils
essaient plutôt un libéral à la
française qui n'ait pas pour la
destruction créatrice m'enfin laissons
ça de côté
mais effectivement le la magie sarkozy
c'était d'avoir su rassembler mais
attention je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
droite ne peut pas se projeter aussi
vite dans un sauveur providentiel ou elf
ou il faut qu'elle rompre avec le maître
le messianisme du sauveur
le messianisme du chef je sais que c'est
difficile parce que à droite on aime les
chefs mais il faut qu'il faut qu'elle
rompe avec ça pour quoi
parce qu'on mais je vais très vite on
est dans une accélération des rythmes
politique qui fait que le retour de
quelqu'un comme nicolas sarkozy hervé a
raison ça serait vraiment le retour de
diplodocus ça serait jurassic park
ciblées qui qui ressort de la naphtaline
et qui revient j'ai rien contre j'ai
rien contre
oui mais j'ai rien contre cet homme non
mais j'ai rien contre cet homme j'ai
même dû beaucoup de tours
voyez dans mon propos je pense qu'il a
il a été un très grand leader de la
droite comme la été mandel dans les
allées c'est un immense responsables
politiques mais vous en au passé mais
aujourd'hui pourquoi j'en parle au passé
parce qu'on est dans une israélisation
des cycles politiques certes ça va de
plus en plus vite et donc les retours
regardez pour valls regarder pour
londres sont rendus de plus en plus
difficile alors
will try qui et qui est marquée par une
femme en une sorte d' instabilité qui
font une accélération des cycles et
accélère insolence et des rations grh et
de linas votre point de vue je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord
déjà nos travers notre notre système
politique est loin d'être celui d'israël
et c'est aussi c'est aussi la
proportionnelle qui entraîne ce genre
d'instabilité politique du côté du côté
israélien
rompre pareil avec l'air mécanique d'un
chef
au contraire je pense que c'est ça qui
peut sauver les républicains l'histoire
de france l'a montré on a besoin de gros
zone des hommes qui inspire justement
pour arriver à porter un projet pour
s'exprimer de manière la plus claire la
plus cohérent c'est pour assembler une
partie de la droite c'est macron ces
données ne sont pas là c'est ça la clé
dans la configuration il n'aurait pas
d'espacé pour la droite
moi je n'en tirerai pas aussi vite et je
crois qu'au contraire nicolas sarkozy
serait le candidat idéal pour redresser
les républicains parce que c'est un
personnage de roman
comme l'a été mitterrand comme l'a été
chirac hommes et on a besoin de
personnages de romans en france pour
pouvoir gouverner après le souci les
d'ordre judiciaire c'est à dire que le
jour où nicolas sarkozy revient le
lendemain il est convoqué dans le bureau
du juge d'instruction et je pense qu'il
le sait aussi bien que les sympathisants
et les cadres du des républicains et
même plus chez le juge d'instruction
s'est dressé devant un tribunal
correctionnel
jean christophe buisson je rappelais le
chiffre plus de 31% qui avait fait
nicolas sarkozy
mais c'était au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle de 2007 en
comme chacun se souvient il n'a pas été
réélu et dans une punchline que j'avoue
j'aurais bien aimé trouver
eric zemmour a dit mais c'est parce que
nicolas sarkozy avait promis le kärcher
et on a eu kouchner c'est à dire qu en
quelque sorte on a été un peu déçu par
ce quinquennat mais alexis lacroix ont
posé le bon mot il y avait une magie
sarkozy mais comme tout magicien
quand on quand le coup est éventé quand
on connaît la tactique qui a permis de
faire croire aux gens qu'il y avait
quelque chose d'extraordinaire et bien
on est très déçu effectivement sarkozy
la dynamique était la sienne en 2007 et
qui permettait de rassembler d'ailleurs
dans le numéro du figure manning se
revendent en juillet une photo
extraordinaire de 2007 où sarkozy est
attablé avec autour de lui quarante
personnes
il ya toute la droite tous les leaders
de la droite dont vous entendu parler
depuis 12 ans sont là de wauquiez fillon
passant par copé xavier bertrand morin
au graff arr etc
donc c'est cette image n'est plus
possible aujourd'hui d'abord parce qu'il
a il a créé cette illusion mais qui
s'est dissipé très rapidement parce que
les actes n'ont pas été à la hauteur des
promesses qui ont été faites notamment
dans certains domaines régaliens son
ouverture à gauche a exaspéré un certain
nombre de gens elle n'était pas viable
c'était d'une certaine manière un échec
et puis surtout il s'est passé quelque
chose il ya deux ans l'élection d
emmanuel macron qui a considéré mme en
bouleverser le paysage politique en
profondeur et du son bien sûr mais parce
qu'on a regardé à gauche
même jacques julliard dans fillon trouve
le moyen nous dire que françois hollande
ne serait le meilleur candidat de la
gauche pour une prochaine élection
on est nostalgique on est nostalgique je
crois pas non non c'était très argumenté
sait déjà que c'était sérieux
c'était un convaincant même situation
que vous avez vous avez cette semaine
c'est cette semaine l'un des nombreux
veulent vous avez sarko pour la droite
puisque nostalgie mais françois hollande
pour la gauche fermé et puis ensuite on
commence en sarkozie la question est
est-ce qu'il doit revenir d'abord c est
ce qu il peut revenir effectivement il
ya un procès qui est premier dernière
dont temps que ce procès ne sera pas
terminé il est hors de question qu'ils
reviennent par ailleurs il est toujours
là il n'a pas il est pas vraiment partie
parce qu'il est très présent il encore
déjeuné avec laurent wauquiez il
distille ses conseils ses avis il a
surtout à la campagne européenne
oui mais la dynamisation il a dit un mot
après élections de dimanche dernier dit
il n'ya plus de droite
qu'est ce que vous voulez qu'ils
reviennent alors que lui-même consid
constate qu'il n'y a plus de droite dans
d'abord qu'elle se repenser qu'elle se
reconstruise
il va pas arriver à la tête d'un champ
de ruines par définition peut-être
qu'après après ses ennuis judiciaires
une fois réglés et selon le paysage
nouveau qui écumera apparu
avec peut-être des ralliements peut-être
des dissensions peut-être des
divergences peut-être qu il émergera
mais en tout cas plongé dans les
prochains mois c'est pour lui hors de
question
ge a jugé ajoute juste pour les lecteurs
impatients que c'est vendredi et non pas
demain que sortira le fameux figure sur
les tablettes par ou demain on va se
ruer dessus pour ce qu'ils sont mais
alors guillot encore un mot moi j'ai un
doute mais je pense que d'autres
ici ils ont la réponse moi j'ai un doute
sur le for intérieur de nicolas sarkozy
donc on va faire un exercice de
sarkologies ciblées est ce que vraiment
depuis deux ans nicolas sarkozy dans son
for intérieur s'est présenté dans les
déjeuners que vous relatez
jean-christophe comme quelqu'un qui
était un opposant au maquereau nisme je
ne crois pas je crois que db oui mais je
mais attendez c'est fondamental je crois
si vous voulez qu'ils voient avec raison
je vous dis pas que salle en salle en
chante mais il voit au fond dans ce
président qui n'est pas issu de son de
sa famille politique
quelqu'un qui réalise une part des
réformes que lui même aurait
certainement dans son for intérieur aimé
mener à bien
veut-il donc jouer en quelque sorte
l'alternance en 2012 par exemple en 2022
contre emmanuel macron je n'en suis pas
sûr
ces relations d'air sont réputés être
assez amical quoique ambivalente
donc je ne suis vraiment je ne sens pas
nicolas sarkozy comme l'homme qui va
monter demain sur le podium en disant
c'est moi le chef de la droite et vous
allez voir je vais vous sauver du
barrage je ne sens pas comme ça de
lecteurs non plus d'ailleurs nos
internautes plus exactement ce qu'ils
sont en train de nous suivre et à qui
nous avons posé la question sur twitter
nicolas sarkozy doit-il revenir sur la
scène politique c'est du deux tiers un
tiers mais 64% qui disent non je vous
livre deux commentaires celui de yoann
sarkozy appartient au passé même s'il
reste un homme d'exception
babineau je suis d'accord il faut
dépasser ce mythe du sauveur surtout que
les ennuis judiciaires de nicolas
sarkozy sont devant lui parce que j'ai
dit précédemment c'est que c'est quand
même le seul qui a la stature pour
s'imposer aux autres
dans la famille on ne voit personne en
capacité de faire taire les ambitions ni
d'en écouter c'est moi le patron lui
seul peut le faire à cause justement du
fait qu'il ait gouverné qu'il était
et qu'il a rassemblé la famille ilan est
le seul à avoir la stature je ne peux
pas penser que le président du sénat
toute façon s qualité ne peut pas
devenir président d'un parti c'est
contraire au moins dans ses institutions
à l'esprit des institutions et puis on
pourrait après derrière y compris pour
des gens comme xavier bertrand ça sera
difficile
lui seul peut dire arriver pas un jour
il hier voilà je m'assois dans le
fauteuil et c'est moi le patron
après moi je pense ce serait une impasse
pour toutes les raisons qu'on a dit ici
d'abord il ya un point judiciaire
mais ce sera aussi une impasse
conceptuel parce que ce qu'il avait
présenté en 2007 est vrai en 2012 est
déjà présentée par d'autres courants
politiques qui ont tracé le sillon et on
n'arrive pas à rebattre les cartes comme
ça simplement monsieur sur une
personnalité je ne crois pas à ça même
si effectivement l'homme fort c'est
important pour la droite
à l'instar de vous une possibilité de
faire une synthèse incarné dans
quelqu'un qui peut-être n'existe pas
même façon qu'il maniait le maquereau
n'apparaissait pas comme quelqu'un
capable de se présenter aux
présidentielles et gagner il ya cinq ans
donc je sais pas une question de sova
c'est une question à mon nez de
quelqu'un qui peut ramasser des courants
et sur sa personne sur son identité
mais ça là dessus je pas d'accord ça
peut être nicolas sarkozy pour plein
d'autres raisons parce que justement une
à cette expérience delà de la
gouvernance 7 cette capacité de synthèse
abandonné le conviction de
d'entraînement mais ça relève de sa de
sa volonté et sa vente ait personne même
pas brice hortefeux ne la connais je
pense
il est certain que nicolas sarkozy c'est
un homme qui inspire ce qui n'est pas le
cas de valérie pécresse françois baroin
ou objets libertins dans une autre
mesure donc c'est très difficile de
trouver un autre candidat plus légitime
que lui maintenant les changes qu'on a
là actuellement autour du plateau montre
bien une chose c'est que on il ya une
espèce de vide quand au programme et la
ligne dlr on est en train de se demander
si un espace pour eux s'ils sont plus ou
moins proches dans marges
quel est le poids accordé au
conservatisme dans le nouveau projet
est-ce qu'on revient à l'appel de cochin
ou pas comment se positionne sur les
questions relatives à la souveraineté
et là il ya un vide qui paraît presque
abyssale pour les l air et avant même de
se poser peut-être la question du
dirigeant ça sera celle de la direction
que va prendre
ces partis moi je pense qu'un espace qui
existent en jeu je veux pas me résoudre
à croire que en marche peu tout aspiré
maintenant il faut pas lui laisser cette
possibilité et il faut que les as l'air
arrive un petit peu à voile à avoir un
propos et un discours on n'écrit pas
parce qu'on a quelque chose à dire mais
parce qu'on a envie de dire quelque
chose pendant la campagne ce qui nous
ont montré ce qu'ils avaient envie de
parler sans avoir rien à dire
aujourd'hui il va falloir résoudre cette
équation entendait pour aller dans le
sens de rachel j'entendais henri guaino
qui a toujours d'ailleurs une influence
à droite comme ancien speechwriter de
nicolas sarkozy ah bon c'est quelqu'un
qui compte à droite qui disait au fond
il faisait passer le salut mais il
disait peut-être qu'il faut qu'on
revienne au gaullisme réinterroger de
l'actualité du gaullisme ce qui serait
d'ailleurs un moyen sans faire du de
l'appel de cochin sans faire du
souverainisme à lille à l'étonnant mais
le souverainisme est préemptée par le
rassemblement national c'est le problème
c'est que ça fait qu'il soit un parti de
la droite reconnaît le droit doit se
distinguer du réseau national
donc le soleil ne peut pas être l'alpha
et l'oméga de la droite demain mais en
revanche le gaullisme oui et donc ça
c'est vrai que la piste donné par
ouverte par guaino me paraît devoir être
inscrite au coeur de l'entreprise de
refondation à laquelle larcher et
sarkozy vont participer aux fondations
tant qu'il y aura des arrière pensées
électorales aujourd'hui ce qui bloque
une reconstruction des écoles de la
droite c'est l'idée qu'il ya des
élections dans un an et qu'il faut se
positionner pour garder sa mairie en
l'occurrence donc les plutôt proche de l
arm ou pas très proche devient donc tant
qu'on n'aura pas passer cette phase là
toute façon ça sera un champ de ruines
parce que chacun en proposant programme
aura peur de perdre élections
municipales et ben on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge